hi Mike how are you today I'm doing
great - how are you okay what do you
think of my my catch rule the
modifications here let's not add any
more language the worst thing they could
do and they've suggested going back to
square one and starting over again no no
minor tweaks are all you need and what
you're saying absolutely right the
boundaries get treated differently the
goal-line gets treated differently and I
would add one thing to what you said if
you catch the ball or break the plane
it's not a fumble at that point it's a
touchdown if you lose possession once
the ball touches the front end of the
goal line plays over I'm fine with that
yeah that's that's what it should be I'd
add one more thing because there's a
three-step process for determining a
catch one did you actually get your
hands on the ball - did you get two feet
or a knee a hip a but whatever on the
ground and three did you have the ball
long enough to clearly become a runner
that third part should not be subject to
replay review ever it should be judgment
of the officials discretionary call just
like pass interference you don't go back
and go frame by frame in 1080i with
every little grain and buzz the Balch no
let the ruling on the field stands that
would overturn the Dez Bryant debacle
that would have made Jesse James catch a
touchdown if they just make element
three not subject to replay review 99.9%
of these problems get fixed thank you
Mike official introduction Mike Florio
pro football live on NBCSN returns to
NBC next monday it's 7:00 a.m. Eastern
also a contributor to NBC football night
in America New York Times splashy
headline Roger Goodell expected to
demand millions of dollars from Jerry
Jones I said about 15 minutes ago I
don't he's not demanding I think Jerry
is required to pay this as legal fees
that Rogers not fining Jerry Jones what
are you hearing about this whole
situation and how big is this situation
it initially it initially Dan was
reported as a fine for conduct
detrimental to the league which the
Commissioner has the power to do up to
five hundred thousand dollars anything
more than that there's a separate
procedure that needs to be initiated
culminating in at least 75% of the
owners signing off if you're going to
find him two million dollars a million
dollars five million whatever you have
to go through this separate procedure
this other thing and this is what it
actually is I mean
got this wrong initially it's not a fine
it's not for conduct detrimental it
comes under and I'm looking at it right
now 1997 resolution FC six its provision
that says if you are involved in a
lawsuit as a member club as the Cowboys
if you initiate a lawsuit or if you
substantially assist someone else's
lawsuit against the league or any of its
teams and you lose you've got to pay the
legal fees yeah and that's what's going
on here but here's where it becomes
fascinating dan because the two elements
one the the pushback the effort to keep
the commissioner from getting an
extension and to involvement in the
Ezekiel 8 suspension as a relation to
the commissioner all he ever did was
threaten litigation and there's no
provision in this resolution for
threatening litigation it only kicks in
if you actually sue I think the Cowboys
have a darn good argument that any legal
fees coming out of that it's not covered
because there never was a lawsuit there
never was a legal proceeding and as to
Elliot I don't know how you prove the
Cowboys substantially assisted them
because they stayed out of it now they
submitted one document on behalf of
their general counsel who gave testimony
in the form of an affidavit other than
that they weren't involved in it so I
think the Cowboys if they want to push
this and you know Jerry Jones may stand
up and say this is exactly why I had
concerns about the commissioner this is
the kind of abusive use of the rules
aimed at retribution and and revenge
because I had the audacity to take on
his effort to get a new contract if
Jones wants a fight this it could get
very interesting yeah I was told that
Jerry still out for blood with Roger
Goodell and I don't know what that means
and it wasn't clarified to me and if I
was a better reporter I would have said
how can he get blood out of said
Commissioner how can he well there
really isn't much more he can do at this
point the Commissioner has an extension
that pays him what two hundred million
dollars over the next five or six years
but he can point to this effort right
here if he's willing to stand up and say
this is exactly what I was talking about
this is exactly the kind of stuff that
happens where the league decides it's
gonna find a rule any rule out there
that it can to to jam a punishment onto
somebody because it wants to punish them
because what they should do here they
should if they believe that Jerry Jones
crossed the line they should initiate
the process for punishing it for conduct
detrimental
but they found this way around it where
they don't have to get the approval of
any other owners they can they can put
whatever inflated legal bills they want
on the tab the Commissioner has final
say on how all this gets worked out and
I I think that that this would be if
Jerry chooses to stand up and do it this
would be a great example for the media
for the fans for everyone on how the NFL
engages in selective enforcement of
rules and overreaches in its
interpretation of the rules to get to a
desired outcome and the desired outcome
here is stick it to Jerry Jones Mike
Florio pro football live joining us Dan
Patrick show what are the Vikings doing
at quarterback you know there's never
been a time Dan in the history of the
league where you've had a team that has
three free agent quarterbacks and any
other option that they want to pursue at
quarterback and at some point you got to
pick one and that's a good thing if you
pick the right one well boy what if you
pick somebody that's never played for
you before you don't know anything about
and it becomes a Brock Osweiler in
Houston situation meanwhile the three
guys you let walk away end up thriving
elsewhere
I mean this could blow up on the Vikings
or it could work out perfectly there's
some steam that they're going to make a
play for Kirk Cousins which does have
risk I didn't to meet with the guy I'd
want to have a meal with him I want to
talk to him before I commit to making
him the highest-paid player in NFL
history the way that these contracts
play out though people want to know
who's committed so they can move on to
the next option will Kirk Cousins slam
the brakes on this process and say I'm
not signing right out of the gate I'm
not signing sight-unseen
I want to meet with the Vikings I want
to meet with the Broncos I want to meet
with the Jets I want to meet with
whoever almost like what Peyton Manning
did six years ago that's what he needs
to do because the worst thing the
cousins or the Vikings can do is sign
this contract and then realize too much
from now my god we hate each other so
the Vikings have have a real challenge
here to get this one right they got a
lot of options and they could they could
lay the foundation for long-term success
or they could screw everything up by
picking the wrong guy would you make of
the Blake bortles extension you know at
first I thought oh my god they're paying
them 18 million a year but then I pulled
up the list of the the annual rate for
all the starting quarterbacks 18 million
like no it's not bad at all listen he's
like 19th but if we assume that cousins
and Case Keenum and AJ McCarron are all
going to get more than 18 million a year
and I don't know about Keenum and
McCarran
I think the bortles contract kind of had
a collective effect of making everyone
take a step back and say maybe the money
is not going to be as crazy as we think
it is but even then bortles is in the
bottom half of the league and one of the
reasons he's in front of ten or eleven
guys is because they're working under
the terms of a rookie contract that they
can't renegotiate yet so this is a very
affordable deal it gives the Jaguars
flexibility it gives them someone they
know that avoids that Brock Osweiler
risk but you're gonna sign someone in
free agency and don't Blake bortles and
then the new guy comes in and it's like
we hate this guy what are we doing so
there with a guy they like it's it's a
sign to all the young players in the
organization if you do everything you're
expected to do you're gonna have a
financial reward here you're not going
to have to go get it somewhere else and
from bortles perspective dan if if the
Jaguars aren't paying them eighteen
million a year if they cut him who's
gonna pay him eighteen million a year I
mean it's a perfect win-win situation
for both sides how did the brown screw
this up the draft well yeah I you know I
found the Browns what do i do do I do I
make an all-in play for a veteran free
agent or do I roll the dice yet again on
a rookie quarterback because the problem
is you may pick the wrong guy and then
you may leave on the board
the guy who becomes the franchise
quarterback we've seen them do it each
of the last two years with Carson Wentz
and deshaun Watson do they pick the
wrong guy at one they picked the wrong
guy at four I have had people joke
around hey they should draft a
quarterback with both spots and they'll
be sure to get one who can play but I
you know I I've seen reports that
they're not enamored with anyone in this
quarterback class and the draft are they
quietly trying to get a free agent how
do you convince someone to go to
Cleveland without grossly overpaying
this is a real challenge for the Browns
they have to get this quarterback
situation right they know it and it's
the first order of business for the new
GM John Dorsey get the right quarterback
in there who's not going to be just a
part-time short-term guy but a guy who
who becomes the foundation of the
franchise for years to come
thank you Mike good to hear from you
again good talking to you Dan thank you
Mike Mike Florio profile
Paul talk for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]